اهلا بكم الى موجز لاهم الانباء قالت
اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي ان وزاره العدل
الامريكيه ابلغت وزاره العدل الاسرائيليه
بفتح تحقيق في واشنطن بشان مقتل الزميله
شيرين ابو عقله اوضحت اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان واشنطن ابلغت وزاره العدل
الاسرائيليه باحتمال طلب موده وشهادات
للتحقيق في وفاه ابو عقله
من جهته قال وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
بينغانس ان قرار وزاره العدل الامريكيه
التحقيق فيما وصفه بالموت المؤسف لشيرين
ابو عقله خطا جسيم اضاف انه اوضح للولايات
المتحده ان تل ابيب تقف وراء الجنود الجيش
الاسرائيلي ولن تتعاون مع اي تحقيق خارجي
اجر مدير وكاله المخابرات المركزيه
الامريكيه سي اي اي ويليام برنس محادثات
مع رئيس المخابرات الروسيه سرجين نارشكين
في انقره وقال مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
المحادثات تهدف لنقل رساله تتعلق بعواقب
اي استخدام من جانب موسكو للاسلحه النوويه
الاستراتيجيه بمجلس الامن الاقاليم
الامريكيه جون كربي للجزيره الولايات
المتحده ستواصل دعم القوه الاخرانيه
التفاوض مع روسيا
انطلاقه في جزيره اسبانيا الاندونيسيا
اعمل قمه المجموعه 20 ونقالات وكاله
الصحافه الفرنسيه عن مسوده بيان القمه ان
استخدام السلاح النووي او التهديد به غير
مسموح
قال البيت الابيض ان الرئيس
بين البلدين يجب ان لا يتحول ابدا الى
الصراع في قمه على هامشي قمه العشرين ابلغ
بيضا
بضروره اداره واشنطن المنافسه بينهما
والحفاظ على قنوات الاتصال في حين دعى
الرئيس الصيني لتصحيح مسار العلاقات بين
البلدين وقال ان تايوان ستبقى الخط الاحمر
الاول لبلاده
قال وزير الداخليه التركي الاوليه تشير
الى مسؤوليه حزب العمال الكردستاني عن
هجوم اسطنبول واعلانات وزاره الداخليه
القاء القبض على المشتبهي في تنفيذها
التفجير واعتقاله 46 شخصا اخرين كانوا
يستعدون لتنفيذ هجمات في مناطق تركيا
مختلفه وقالت السلطات التركيه انها سوريه
الجنسيه وجاب تدريبها من قبل حزب العمال
الكردستاني ووحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه